euh et tout de suite place au second au
second débat sommes-nous en train de
vivre un choc compare un choc économique
comparable à ceux qu'on a pu vivre dans
les années 70 sommes-nous à la veille
d'une récession mondiale c'est le
parallèle que fait le Centre d'études
prospective et d'information
internationales dans son dernier état de
l'économie mondiale 2023 à ce détail
près selon les auteurs c'est que la
situation actuelle est encore plus
explosive chronique d'une récession
annoncée avec Flora sauvage
crise énergétique en Europe
osent des taux d'intérêt aux États-Unis
confinement et crise immobilière en
Chine tous les indicateurs passent au
rouge la perspective d'une récession
mondiale émerge c'est-à-dire une
croissance négative pendant au moins
deux trimestres après la BCE la Fed aux
États-Unis relève à nouveau ses taux
pour tenter de juguler l'inflation alors
que l'économie britannique devrait
entrer en récession dès le troisième
trimestre on a les entreprises qui sont
confrontées à des factures énergétiques
très élevées et on ne sait pas comment
va se passer l'hiver d'un point de vue
simplement de et donc est-ce que les
entreprises qui se le souhaitent vont
pouvoir rester ouverte ou est-ce qu'il
va y avoir des délaissages mais ce sont
quand même tout des éléments mis
ensemble qui tendent à penser que on va
vers la récession la question c'est de
savoir si elle a déjà commencé au 3e
trimestre ou elle ne commencera qu'au
quatrième trimestre donc la contraction
de l'activité mais il y a
malheureusement peu d'indicateurs à
l'heure actuelle qui permettent
d'espérer qu'on y échappe toucher de
plein fouet par la guerre en Ukraine la
zone euro connait sa pire inflation
depuis 40 ans ce qui inquiète les
économistes je pense qu'il y aura plutôt
un très fort ralentissement de la
croissance c'est à dire qu'on aura une
croissance positive mais très légèrement
positive entre 0,5 08 on parle pour
l'Allemagne la France ce serait plutôt
autour de 1% donc un très fort
ralentissement de croissance et on
espère et ça devrait être quand même le
cas d'avoir quand même une politique
monétaire qui soit efficace alors pas
cette année mais plutôt l'année
prochaine on va continuer d'augmenter
les taux d'intérêt ça va juguler
l'inflation et ça devrait créer plus de
confiance dans les ménages
outre-Atlantique la les herbes fédérales
américaines fait tout pour ramener
l'inflation autour de 2% quitte à
imposer des conséquences douloureuses
pour les ménages comme pour les
entreprises
alors alerte la récession planétaire on
en parle ce soir avec mes invités
bonsoir Thomas quebi bonsoir vous êtes
économiste responsable du programme
macroéconomie et finance internationale
aux cépi justement dont on parlait
chaque œil à vos côtés Mireille chirolo
Assouline vous êtes économisé de
l'environnement professeur de sciences
économiques à l'université parisien
Panthéon Sorbonne et puis un habitué son
public Raphaël Legendre journaliste
économique à l'opinion et puis bien sûr
Laetitia coupa qui est resté à mes côtés
je voudrais qu'on commence quand même
par ce constat est-ce qu'on peut ou non
parler aujourd'hui de récession mondiale
on rappelle ce déclaré session un de
trimestre on l'a vu de de baisse
consécutives globalement ça se constate
après coup une récession non mais ça se
constate après coup mais là il y a des
signes et des signaux en tout cas que la
situation économique mondiale se dégrade
fortement par rapport au mois de juillet
par exemple on a perdu près de deux
points dans les prévisions de croissance
dans la zone euro en espérant encore
qu'en 2023 on soit autour de 2% de
croissance là maintenant il y a des
projections très négative donc voilà
donc la situation se dégrade et se
dégrade assez rapidement j'ai posé une
question un peu peut-être provocante
mais est-ce qu'on peut faire confiance
aux prévisions on sait que alors
peut-être moins actuellement mais les
macroéconomistes se sont longtemps
parfois tromper sur leur prévision c'est
vrai que on se trompe beaucoup mais il y
a quand même des signaux qui sont
alarmants alors il y a deux types de
signaux si on prend par exemple la
situation française une grosse
inquiétude c'est ce qui va se passer
avec la demande c'est à dire que lorsque
vous avez une hausse de l'inflation une
augmentation des prix et que les
salaires ne suivent pas et qu'est-ce que
ça signifie ça signifie que vous avez
une base du pouvoir d'achat du coup les
gens achètent et donc ils vont moins
chez les commerçants mais au restaurant
et donc vous avez une dégradation des
carnets de commandes donc ça c'est la
première inquiétude la deuxième
inquiétude c'est du côté de l'offre et
ça c'est plus lié à la crise énergétique
et donc l'augmentation de la facture et
énergétique pourrait conduire beaucoup
de firmes beaucoup d'entreprises à
arrêter de produire et donc vous avez
cette concomitance de deux chocs qui
nous permettent d'anticiper le fait que
ça ralentissement plus important que ce
qu'on anticipait encore il y a quelques
mois on voyait à l'instant les chiffres
de des prévisions de de croissance par
zone mondiale on va venir au cas de la
France mais d'abord on va faire comme un
zoom sur les sur les gros moteurs
mondiaux vous voyez cette croissance on
baisse dans le monde en baisse aux
États-Unis en baisse sans la zone euro
et puis avec peut-être une petite hausse
sur la Chine mais bien inférieure à ce
qu'on a pu connaître les années
précédentes est-ce que le parallèle avec
les chocs pétroliers vous parlez
justifier Raphaël est-ce qu'on peut
parler de choc gazier par exemple
complètement un choc énergétique
équivalent à ce qu'on a pu connaître
dans les années 70 effectivement c'est
pas compliqué en 18 mois on a eu une
multiplication par 10 des coûts de
l'énergie du gaz et l'électricité c'est
un changement absolument majeur pour
l'économie européenne en général et
française en particulier parce qu'il
faut bien comprendre une chose c'est que
la transition énergétique est en train
de bouleverser la donne jusqu'à présent
on avait un prix du baril qui était à
peu près le même de partout autour du
monde l'unité référence
le tour du monde c'était le baril de
pétrole quand le pétrole était haut tout
le monde le payait au sauf les pays
producteurs évidemment quand il était
bas tout le monde l'avait bah
aujourd'hui le marché énergétique est un
marché local c'est-à-dire que le coût du
gaz d'électricité n'est pas le même en
Europe qu'aux États-Unis qu'en Chine et
malheureusement aujourd'hui puisque
l'Europe est très dépendante du gaz
notamment et des importations de gaz
pour produire son énergie l'énergie
majeure qui va devenir l'énergie de
référence dans un monde décarboné et
bien on a aujourd'hui une électricité
qui coûte 6 fois plus cher en Europe
qu'aux États-Unis ou en Chine et c'est
un élément majeur pour la perte de
compétitivité européenne et pour
l'économie européenne au sens large
Mireille Assouline j'ai posé une autre
question provocante est-ce que c'est si
grave dans la session après tout on peut
se dire qu'on en a connu en 2020 avec la
crise covid et que c'est reparti comme
sur des chapeaux de roue peu après pour
que nos téléspectateurs comprennent bien
c'est quoi les conséquences d'une
récession si elle s'installe les
conséquences d'une récession c'est quand
même
un poids important sur les ménages
surtout ceux qui ont le moins de
capacité d'adapter d'adaptation
c'est
un poids là aussi important sur l'emploi
sur le chômage
nous connaissons actuellement en France
un taux d'emploi
exceptionnellement haut avec un taux de
chômage exceptionnellement bas c'est
forcément quelque chose qui va qui va
changer si nous connaissons une
récession maintenant au niveau français
il n'est pas absolument sûr que cette
récession se produise on va y venir en
fait c'est tout tout dépend le temps que
ça dure non
si c'est juste deux trimestres de baisse
consécutifs ou si c'est quelque chose
qui s'installe si c'est juste deux
trimestres consécutifs on pourrait
considérer que c'est seulement une pause
dans la croissance c'est ce qu'on
appelle une récession technique oui on
pourrait dire ça c'est à dire que la
définition technique est remplie mais ce
n'est pas forcément une situation très
grave dans l'ensemble de l'économie
maintenant si la production s'arrête
ça peut avoir des conséquences beaucoup
beaucoup plus lourdes alors je voudrais
qu'on fasse un petit peu un tour des
moteurs de la croissance dans l'ordre en
commençant par parler de ce qui se passe
en Chine parce que depuis deux décennies
il faut le dire c'était le moteur de la
croissance c'est ce qui est sûr je crois
un quart de de la croissance mondiale à
lui tout seul enfin ce pays et puis
alors on va voir qu'est-ce qui se passe
en Chine
qui ne conseiller Raphaël crise
immobilière majeur en Chine c'est un des
problèmes effectivement au niveau
mondial on a une sorte de tempête
économique parfaite avec les trois
moteurs Chine Europe États-Unis qui sont
en train de se gripper en même temps en
Chine c'est pas la guerre du crâne le
marché pour expliquer aux spectateurs
c'est qui qui pèse sur l'Europe
énormément bien sûr mais pour la Chine
c'est parce qu'il est possible c'est la
crise immobilière très clairement qui
couve depuis déjà quelques années
l'immobilier c'était incarne la
croissance chinoise la croissance
chinoise étant elle-même un moteur
déterminant de la croissance mondiale
c'est la Chine qui nous a permis en
Europe de maintenir l'inflation plutôt
basse de pouvoir acheter des produits
peu chers de nourrir notre croissance
également
aujourd'hui le marché immobilier
s'effondre on a vu des images absolument
terribles des immeubles neufs 100
personnes à l'intérieur qui était
détruits et des gens qui ont acheté sur
le pouvoir chinois ces gens qui doivent
rester sur plan qui refusent dorénavant
de rembourser leur prêt parce qu'ils ont
tout simplement peur de ne plus pouvoir
récupérer leur bien immobilier avant
avant qu'il ait fini de construire et
donc vous avez des géants des mastodons
de l'immobilier en Chine evergondé par
exemple 300 milliards de dettes
est un mastodonte qui a eu du mal fin
2021 à rembourser certaines échéances
plusieurs milliardaires
on est on est en train d'éclater elle
est comme toujours en Chine piloter par
Pékin bien sûr donc Pékin va mettre
énormément d'argent pour essayer de la
limiter mais un plan 380 milliards
d'euros par les autorités chinoises
effectivement mis sur la table cet été
pour essayer de relancer la croissance
chinoise mais il y a énormément de
risques sur le la contamination que la
chute du secteur immobilier pourrait
faire notamment au secteur
financiers tout ça encore une fois est
assez opaque c'est en Chine et gérer
très directement par l'État qui ne
laissera pas l'économie complètement
s'effondrée mais on a d'un côté cette
crise immobilière extrêmement importante
et inquiétante pour nous occidentaux et
également la politique anti-covide oui
parce que il y a aussi des suites du
covid à l'économie chinoise avec ce stop
and go un peu permanent avec des
confinements à répétition sur
les cœurs économiques de la Chine
Shanghai
l'activité ça décourage les
investissements à venir aussi et ça a
des conséquences surtout au niveau
mondial c'est à dire que quand on ferme
pendant des semaines des usines de
production pour des produits qui sont
censés aller vers l'Europe et les
États-Unis ça a des conséquences très
concrètes sur toute la Supply chaîne et
chaîne logistique mondiale la Chine
c'est l'entreprise c'est l'usine du
monde et quand l'usine du monde s'arrête
et bien c'est le globe qui tousse
si la Chine chute qui peut prendre sa
succession qui peut être le nouveau
moteur de l'économie mondiale
la Chine ne va pas s'effondrer c'est à
dire que si Jean pin tient son congrès
en fin d'année va être reconduit au
pouvoir pour un troisième mandat et il
ne laissera pas l'économie chinoise
s'effondrer vous avez autour des
satellites les tigres asiatiques comme
on dit qui peuvent aider un peu prendre
le relais peut-être aussi l'Inde mais la
Chine reste le producteur majeur de bien
manufacturé pour le reste du monde et de
plus en plus indépendant et de plus en
plus souvent aussi ce qu'on assiste
plutôt sur le long terme c'est un
découplage des économies entre la Chine
et les États-Unis notamment les deux se
refermant de plus en plus sur eux et
l'Europe au milieu qui cherche la voie
de la souveraineté mais dont beaucoup de
dirigeants d'entreprises aussi
réfléchissent à l'avenir des relations
commerciales avec la Chine qui est qui
est de plus en plus on dit aussi qu'il y
a quand même une forme de vieillissement
de la population active et aussi un défi
démographique de baisse de la
productivité ce qui est assez nouveau
qu'est-ce qu'ici on traverse qu'est-ce
qui se passe de l'autre côté aux
États-Unis parce que là c'est pas
tellement la guerre en Ukraine on
rappelle que le prix du gaz il est 8
fois moins cher qu'en Europe c'est pas
non plus ils sont plus tellement dans le
covid
là-bas c'est les prix qui monte c'est
l'inflation le problème ça monte alors
il y a un grand débat parmi les
économistes aux États-Unis pour essayer
d'expliquer ce que ça vient de la
demande le fait que notamment les
présidents Biden a fait des plans de
relance qui serait trop massif et donc
il y aurait une surchauffe de l'économie
américaine donc ça c'est une partie de
d'économiste comme leur en Sommers
qui défendent un peu cette cette opinion
et puis vous avez d'autres qui disent ça
vient plutôt des prix de l'énergie et
donc la fête fait une grosse erreur en
augmentant les taux parce que ça risque
d'aggraver la situation éc donc on n'a
pas identifié les causes les causes de
la réalisation il y a les salaires qui
aussi des demandes de rattrapage de
salaire il y a certains c'est que quand
on compare par rapport à la situation de
la zone euro il y a plus les hausses de
salaire sont plus importantes aux
États-Unis là les derniers chiffres sur
trois mois c'est presque 6 %
d'augmentation des salaires donc
l'inflation est toujours supérieure un
peu au dessus du pour cent mais quand
même vous avez des hausses de salaires
qui sont beaucoup plus importantes que
dans la zone euro donc l'idée d'une
surchauffe de l'économie américaine et
plus crédible en tout cas que ce qu'on
voit dans la zone euro et alors la
paradoxalement parce que vous vous
faisiez allusion et pour que nos
téléspectateurs comprennent c'est
l'action de la Réserve fédérale la
banque centrale américaine qui pourrait
d'une certaine façon ralentir l'activité
je vous propose d'écouter Jérôme Powell
le président de la Fed
nous devons mettre l'inflation derrière
nous j'aimerais qu'il y ait une façon
indolore de le faire il n'y en a pas
donc ce que nous devons faire c'est
amener les taux au point où nous
mettrons une pression significative vers
le bas sur l'inflation
alors laeticiel disait c'est technique
il faudrait que essayer d'expliquer à
notre téléspectateurs pourquoi
l'inflation c'est pire que la récession
bah c'est pas je pense que c'est pas
pire mais en soi la Jérôme Powell pense
très clairement qu'il y a une surchauffe
de l'école de l'économie américaine et
qu'en gros ce qui se passe c'est que
quand vous anticipez des hausses de prix
les ménages ou les entreprises accordent
des hausses de salaire et donc ce qui
craigne c'est ce que les économistes
appellent une boucle prix salaire les
poses de salaire nourrissent les hausses
de prix et ainsi de suite donc ça c'est
clairement ce que est-ce que suggère
ça mène à des hausses de prix de plus en
plus importantes et donc le l'opinion de
la fête c'est qu'il y a un moment il
faut durcir augmenter fortement les taux
pour casser ça pour casser ça et en fait
l'idée c'est de reproduire ce qui
s'était passé à la fin des années 70 ou
le président de la fête de l'époque
Monsieur Walker avait augmenté très
fortement les taux de près de 9 points
entre 1979 et 80 et le résultat ça avait
été une récession aux États-Unis et une
augmentation forte du chômage parce que
alors il y a une conséquence à ça quand
même je vous propose de regarder cette
citation d'Isabelle chabel elle est
membre du directoire de la Banque
centrale européenne et elle était réunie
le 27 août avec
Jackson hall aux États-Unis ou se tient
la grand-messe annuelle des banquiers
sans trop regarder il faut réagir avec
plus de force à la pousser actuelle
d'inflation même au risque d'une
croissance plus faible et d'un chômage
plus élevé est-ce qu'on est sûr qu'on
fait le bon choix alors il faut bien
voir que c'est la mission des banques
centrales
que ça fait dans les années 90 à
l'économie européenne enfin au chômage
français notamment à peu près toutes les
banques centrales ont cette mission de
stabiliser l'inflation avec des cibles
qui peuvent être différentes suivant le
suivant suivant les pays mais c'est à
priori leur mission et pas tellement la
mission de soutenir la croissance et
donc du point de vue d'un banquier
central il est effectivement judicieux
de lutter contre l'inflation parce que
l'une des conséquences vous demandiez
l'une des conséquences de l'inflation
c'est que ça ne joue pas seulement sur
l'économie interne mais ça joue sur la
compétitivité vis-à-vis de l'extérieur
de production des entreprises s'élèvent
ces entreprises perdent en compétitivité
par rapport à d'autres à d'autres pays
où les prix ne se seraient pas autant
élevés donc
actuellement c'est aussi potentiellement
un risque pour pour les économies qui
connaissent un fort taux d'inflation il
faut comprendre ce qui se joue là aussi
c'est le résultat des apprentis sorciers
qu'on a eu un peu à la tête des banques
centrales que soit aux États-Unis ou en
Europe depuis 10 ans on a fait tourner
la planche à billets comme jamais
souvenu injecter des liquidités on a eu
l'impression qu'on pouvait déverser des
milliards comme si l'on pleuvait sans
aucun problème dans cette crise
notamment dans la crise sanitaire il
fallait le faire c'était dans leur
dépense supplémentaires
trois le bilan de la Banque centrale
européenne
depuis 20 ans forcément on est en train
de se rendre compte aujourd'hui il y a
d'anciens banquiers centraux comme
Jacques de la Rosière tire la sonnette
d'alarme depuis quelques années on est
en train de se rendre compte que à force
de déverser des liquidités et aux
États-Unis ça s'est chiffré en milliers
de milliards de dollars aussi et bien il
se trouve qu'on a de l'inflation à la
sortie et que pour maintenant pour
limiter cette inflation on demande au
même banquier centraux remonter les taux
quitte à cassé la croissance qui là
effectivement risque de sévèrement
ralentir l'année prochaine et l'Europe
dans tout ça on avait des prévisions
plutôt au vert en début d'année et là
tous les voyants sont plutôt rouge là
pour le coup c'est la faute de la guerre
en Ukraine je pense que c'est la faute
de la guerre en Ukraine et je pense que
la BCE fait une erreur de suivre ce que
fait la fête parce que aussi aux
États-Unis il y a des signes de
surchauffe dans la zone euro c'est il y
en a pas c'est à dire vous avez une
inflation qui est autour de 9% dans la
zone euro mais les salaires qui
augmentent beaucoup moins donc le gros
risque la zone euro c'est une baisse
très forte de du revenu des ménages un
effondrement de la demande et donc un
risque fort de récession donc si vous
augmentez les taux alors que déjà vous
avez un risque de récession vous allez
aggraver la récession donc implicitement
je suis d'accord qu'il y a un aspect de
compétitivité il y a aussi un aspect
réduire l'inflation importée puisque
dans la zone euro le gros de l'inflation
ça vient du fait que on importe des
matières premières qui coûtent plus cher
mais on les importe en dollars donc
lorsque l'euro se déprécie ça veut dire
que votre facture coûte encore coûte
encore plus cher donc un pari implicite
de la BCE c'est de dire si on augmente
les taux alors que la Fed elle-même les
augmente ça va permettre de de faire
monter l'euro mais en fait ce qu'on
observe c'est un peu le contraire c'est
à dire que les marchés ils interprètent
pas le fait que la BC augmente les taux
comme la preuve que l'euro va être plus
fort mais au contraire comme le fait que
il y a un risque plus important de
récession ce qui fait encore plus
baisser l'euro donc chaque fois que la
BCE augmente ses tours les marchés
attention il y a un risque de récession
donc le robesp et donc la facture
énergétique pour les Européens augmente
alors je visais un avis de la Booba
enfin la Bundes banque la banque
centrale allemande qui dit que
l'Allemagne est entrée dans une phase de
baisse nette généralisée et durable de
son économie que les signes de récession
se multiplient on a parlé de l'action de
la BCE qui est donc discutable ou en
tout cas discuter est-ce que la
Commission européenne de son côté pour
vous fait le job
la Commission européenne a des objectifs
qui sont différents la Commission
européenne n'a pas la charge de lutter
contre l'inflation
la Commission européenne s'efforce de
maintenir une cohésion de l'ensemble de
l'ensemble des pays qui qui participent
et bien sûr
elle s'efforce aussi de maintenir la
cohérence avec la ligne qui a été fixée
jusqu'à présent et qui est une ligne de
lutte contre le changement climatique
qui un particulièrement difficile à
tenir lorsqu'on est en période de
difficultés pour la croissance
économique les mesures qui ont été
prises par exemple en France mais dans
d'autres pays aussi de limitation des
effets de la hausse des prix
tourne sur sur les prix énergétiques
sont des mesures qui bien sûr
favorise
la consommation et donc réduisent les
risques de de récession mais en revanche
ce sont des des mesures qui sont
extrêmement pernicieuses pour le
changement pour le changement climatique
puisqu'on fait on supprime ce qu'on
appelle le signal prix et que le
consommateur ne prend plus forcément
conscience que les prix vont augmenter
pour moi c'est lutter contre la
récession au risque d'une régression sur
le plan de la lutte contre le changement
est-ce que la Commission fait le job
parce qu'on l'a vu aussi après la crise
covid a été capable pour le coup de
faire une forme d'alliance entre les
pays du frugaux et ce qu'on jugeait
dépensier et d'injecter beaucoup de
milliards dans l'économie dans les
répare refaire ça pour éviter ça qui
effectivement est toujours en cours au
sein de l'Union européenne plus que la
Commission c'est le conseil c'est-à-dire
que les chefs d'État et gouvernement
entre eux qui au cœur de la crise de la
covid en juillet 2020 décide pour la
première fois cette historique en Europe
de créer de de lever un endettement
commun entre tous les pays et de faire
des vrais transferts financiers du nord
au sud notamment effectivement ce moment
à miltonien qu'on a appelé hamiltonien
un peu rapidement et bien on se demande
s'il ne faudrait pas un deuxième plan de
relance aujourd'hui c'était beaucoup un
750 milliards d'euros la France devrait
encore toucher une quinzaine de
milliards d'euros de l'Europe en fin
d'année pour l'aider notamment dans sa
transition énergétique et là les
discussions aujourd'hui sont bien
davantage autour
[Musique]
cette guerre a de sérieuses conséquences
économiques
financière et sociale sur les pays
africains ce conflit se traduit par une
difficulté à financer leurs économies et
une augmentation des prix des produits
de première nécessité et même des cas de
famine en raison de leur dépendance aux
céréales et aux engrais en provenance
d'Ukraine et de Russie
les pays émergents c'est eux qui vont le
plus souffrir de la récession mondiale
les pays émergents les pays les plus
pauvres parce que c'est vrai que par
exemple des pays comme l'Égypte 80% des
importations de blé en Egypte venaient
dukraine donc évidemment c'est des pays
qui à la fois étaient très dépendant
pour le blé ou le maïs de l'Ukraine et
de la Russie qui par ailleurs ont des
marges de manœuvre budgétaires notamment
après le covid qui sont beaucoup plus
faibles et donc le risque c'est qu'avec
l'augmentation des prix des denrées
alimentaires elles aient pas les moyens
de financer ces dépenses alimentaires et
donc ça ça peut avoir des conséquences
dramatiques on parle on parle de famille
il faut voir que déjà en temps normal
entre guillemets dans un pays pauvre le
budget alimentaire ça représente deux
tiers du budget d'un ménage on voit bien
que là c'est en train d'exploser donc il
y a pas d'autres pays producteurs de blé
au même prix que celui de l'Ukraine
alors le problème c'est que vous avez
des questions de stockage et que par
exemple la Chine a stocké 40% des stock
de blé mondiaux donc on a parlé tout à
l'heure des problèmes de
d'approvisionnement de contraintes sur
l'offre le fait que les biens ne
circulent pas à cause de déconfinement à
cause de ça mais il y a aussi le fait
qu'il y a des pays qui stockent
énormément de blé et donc les autres en
partie oui et pour le cas des pays
émergents c'est d'autant plus
problématique qu'ils ont une dette
publique sur le dos ils ont une tête qui
est plus problématique c'est pour les
pays de nouveaux déficitaires qui ont un
déficit courant c'est à dire qui a un
porte plus de matière première qu'elle
n'exporte parce que là on peut retrouver
un scénario qui avait dans les années 80
c'est à dire que vous avez une hausse
des taux de la Fed les marchés
commencent un peu à s'inquiéter donc des
fuites de capitaux qui quittent les pays
émergents pour aller vers les États-Unis
donc les banques centrales au niveau
local sont obligées d'augmenter les taux
de capitaux et il y a des risques
vraiment de crise de la dette dans les
pays émergents c'est ce qu'on a connu il
y a quelques mois par exemple au Sri
Lanka avec là aussi des conséquences
assez dramatiques aussi bien économique
que politique alors on va en venir
maintenant à la situation française ou
des politiques optimistes côtoient des
économistes plus pessimistes on fait le
point avec Tam traduit
et on va s'intéresser donc plus
particulièrement Tam aux prévisions les
économistes sont de moins en moins
optimistes je disais pour pour la France
en 2023 on va commencer par regarder les
chiffres de Bercy pour construire le
budget de l'année prochaine le ministère
de l'économie et des finances a déjà
revu cette prévisions de croissance à la
baisse on est passé de 1,4% de
prévisions ça c'était au mois de juillet
et les dernières prévisions le 13
septembre dernier était à 1% mais c'est
encore très optimiste par rapport aux
prévisions de la Banque de France qui
table sur une activité économique et
comprise entre une hausse de 0,8% et un
repli de 0,5% alors pourquoi une
fourchette et bien parce que c'est la
grande incertitude notamment à cause de
la guerre en Ukraine et le grand flou
sur les prix de l'énergie je vous donne
encore deux autres chiffres celui de
l'institut rexécode qui parle d'une
récession qui touchera l'ensemble du
continent européen et qui voit la France
à 0% de croissance l'année prochaine
voilà la bulle mais c'est encore un
scénario plus agréable que celui de la
banque
sur une baisse de l'activité économique
de
0,7%. c'est une donne avec laquelle il
va falloir composer pour le gouvernement
pour qu'on constituer son budget ça
vient vite c'est la présentation du
projet de loi de finances 2023 il va
être présenté en Conseil des ministres
on en connaît pas encore tous les
détails à même s'il y a des petits
éléments qui fuitent mais il y a une
obsession qui est martelé par Bruno Le
Maire et ça déjà depuis plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois et notamment et
bien le 28 juillet dernier au Sénat
écoutez le rétablissement du finances
publiques françaises n'est pas
négociable il est engagé le président de
la République a fixé un calendrier 3% de
déficit en 2027 et amorcer la baisse de
la dette publique à partir de 2025 je
suis le garant du respect de cet
engagement du Président de la République
du retour à l'équilibre de nos finances
publiques nous devons donc dans nos
débats faire attention à ce que chaque
euro soit bien employé
bon c'est un refrain qu'on entend
souvent dans la bouche de Bruno Le Maire
en l'occurrence il parlait du paquet
pouvoir d'achat c'est la même logique
pour l'année prochaine l'objectif du
gouvernement retrouvé un déficit à 5% du
PIB pour 2023 et que ça baisse encore
pour la suite et pour ça et bien côté
économie ou plutôt il y a des cadeaux
qui lui urgent de ne pas faire un Bercy
a décidé d'étaler sur deux ans la
suppression par exemple de la CVAE un
pot de production dont le patronat
attendait la disparition complètement
2023 ça sera sur deux ans économie 4
milliards pas touche non plus par
exemple aux droits de succession a
malgré les promesses de campagne
d'Emmanuel Macron le rapporteur général
du budget au Sénat Jean-François Husson
l'a dit lorsqu'il est sorti des fameux
dialogues de Bercy il a bien été dit que
ce n'était pas dans le projet de loi de
finances bref pas ce genre de cadeau
alors qu'il va déjà falloir passer
l'hiver financer le bouclier tarifaire
sur l'énergie qui pourrait écouter on
fait pas exactement combien peut-être
des dizaines de milliards d'euros à nos
finances publiques merci beaucoup Tom
le cas français on en parlait est-ce que
le c'est seulement de la faute de
l'Ukraine où est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
raisons je vous dis ça parce que
l'Institut exécode dit que bah oui il y
a la faute de l'Ukraine et aussi des
contraintes qui pèsent sur l'offre la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre des choses
comme ça
sans doute sans doute des questions de
pénurie de main d'oeuvre dans certains
secteurs maintenant on en a beaucoup
parlé dans le secteur du tourisme et
finalement l'activité en tout cas cet
été a été très soutenue dans le secteur
du tourisme donc ça doit ça doit jouer
dans certains secteurs ce qui peut jouer
aussi c'est l'effet goulot
d'étranglement dont on parlait tout à
l'heure à la suite enfin en raison des
blocages de production en Chine et un
certain nombre de secteurs industriels
sont encore gênés par par ces questions
maintenant je pense que c'est quand même
très clairement la situation en Ukraine
qui a fait se dégrader la situation
économique française et on voit bien que
le pessimisme a cru des instituts de
prévisions vient de cette période là
sans la guerre en Ukraine je pense qu'on
en serait toujours à des prévisions
positives pour la croissance en 2023
rappelle le jour des pouvoirs publics
ont beaucoup dépensé pour compenser
cette hausse des prix notamment de
l'énergie au 24 milliards
24 milliards uniquement pour le bouclier
tarifaire c'est depuis l'automne dernier
si on rajoute depuis l'automne dernier
et les mesures anti-inflation et les
mesures pouvoirs d'achat les 20
milliards qui sont passés au mois de
juillet au Parlement on est à une
cinquantaine de milliards d'euros mis en
place pour limiter l'inflation les coûts
de l'énergie et soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat des Français l'année prochaine
le bouclier tarifaire sera maintenu il
sera un peu moins protecteur que ce
qu'on a vécu en 2022 puisque les prix et
du gaz et de l'électricité augmenteront
chacun deux 15%, mais comme les prix ont
les multiplié par 10 il coûtera beaucoup
plus cher 46 milliards d'euros au
finances publiques de l'étage rappelle
que la dette va franchir les 3000
milliards Bruno Le Maire a dit non ça ne
coûtera que 16 milliards nets alors il y
a une différence effectivement entre le
coup brut et ce que Bruno Le Maire
appelle le coup net c'est à dire que les
surprofits il ne faut pas parler de
taxes surprofit au sein du gouvernement
vous l'aurez bien compris mais il existe
un mécanisme qui ressemble quand même
grandement sur tout les producteurs
d'énergie renouvelables pendant des
années pour soutenir ces producteurs
d'énergie éoliennes solaires et autres
on leur a acheté un tarif de
l'électricité à 80 euros du
mégawattheure qui était très supérieurs
au prix de marché qui était autour de 45
ans il se trouve que c'est même
producteurs qui produisent à 80 coût de
production sont à 80 et bien vendre
aujourd'hui à 300 400 500 euros le
Mégawat donc il doit être au céder un
peu énormément d'argent et selon la loi
c'était bien avant la crise énergétique
mais doivent être cédés c'est sur profit
à l'état c'est plus de 20 milliards
d'euros par exemple sur l'éolien et le
solaire qui vont comme ça être ramené
dans les caisses de l'État satanique
donc le coût infinie net effectivement
de du bouclier taille frère devrait être
attendant de voir l'évolution du prix du
marché cette année mais de 16 milliards
dit Bruno Le Maire Thomas que j'ai
bénéfique il faut les plus loin alors on
risque de voir aller plus loin parce que
comme on disait au début de votre
émission il y a un gros risque à la fois
sur les ménages et puis sur les
entreprises aujourd'hui on sait pas
exactement combien d'entreprises vont
s'arrêter il y a de gros inquiétudes
dans le secteur manufacturier on parle
on parlait ces derniers mois beaucoup de
la nécessité de réindustrialiser la
France là le gros risque c'est d'une
nouvelle phase de désindustrialisation
de la France et donc si dans quelques
mois il y a un nombre conséquent
d'entreprises manufacturières qui
s'arrête avec des risques de
délocalisation des suppressions
d'emplois notamment parce qu'on a dit
tout à l'heure les prix du gaz sont
beaucoup plus faibles
sont beaucoup plus faibles pardon aux
États-Unis et moins cher et
l'électricité est plus faible en Chine
là vous allez il y a le gouvernement
sera obligé d'agir donc on part on pense
au chômage partiel le retour du chômage
partiel mais on sera dans un cas assez
différent de il y a 2 ans quand il y
avait les confinements parce que pendant
les confinements ça devait durer deux
trois mois là la crise énergétique peut
durer un an ou deux ans donc ça va être
difficile pour le gouvernement de
financer des mesures de chômage partiel
pendant un an et deux ans et puis ça ne
suffira pas parce que si les entreprises
s'arrêtent ben ça peut avoir des
conséquences à long terme et donc des
conséquences assez catastrophiques sur
notre ce qui reste de notre tissu
industriel et ça ça va plomber
durablement le moral des Français et le
moral ça compte aussi Laetitia vous vous
êtes intéressé à cette question du moral
des Français et vous pensez que les
politiques ont une responsabilité dans
cette sinistrose ambiante et le moral
compte c'est fondamental enfin je veux
dire la planète est composée d'humains
on parle de les chiffres de taux de
récession mais enfin avant tout nous
sommes là tous ce soir autour de cette
table et je peux vous dire que le moral
des Français en cette rentrée est
totalement plombé le sondage odoxa
annuel est paru 8 septembre dernier 77 %
des Français se disent défiant dans
l'avenir c'est pas méfiant Mathieu c'est
défiant dans l'avenir
77%, 9 sont des sur 10 ont peur de
l'inflation au Doxat et formel c'est le
pire niveau de morale pour un mois de
septembre depuis que ce baromètre existe
pourquoi les politiques en particulier
serait responsables de cette sinestrose
je ne dis pas que tous les politiques
crient au loup mais quand même il y en a
un et le premier de ces politiques
Emmanuel Macron qui a sifflé la fin de
la récré la fin de l'été rappelez-vous
ce conseil des ministres filmé
exceptionnellement où il prononçait ces
mots
je crois pour ma part que ce que nous
sommes en train de vivre et plutôt de
l'ordre d'une grande bascule ou d'un
grand bouleversement
d'abord parce que nous vivons et cela va
simplement depuis cet été et ces
dernières années au fond la fin de ce
qui pouvait apparaître comme une
abondance c'est aussi la fin des
évidences quand on regarde à la fois la
France l'Europe et le cours du monde
la démocratie les droits de l'homme si
d'aucun pensait que c'était la
téléologie
de l'ordre international les dernières
années auront battu en brèche quelques
évidences c'est la fin de celle-ci la
montée des régimes il libéraux
renforcement des régimes autoritaires
nous l'avons encore vu dans les discours
désinhibés des derniers mois sont clairs
et cette je dois le dire aussi la fin
pour qui en avait d'une forme
d'insouciance voilà c'est la fin c'est
ce qu'on retient tous
de l'abondance de l'évidence et de
l'insouciance et alors le même jour
françois Bayrou dans le point lui il va
carrément sans aucune nuance il estime
que la France va vers la crise la plus
grave qu'elle est connue depuis la
guerre et qui ne pourra être surmonter
sans un immense effort national en
ajoutant cette immense effort nationale
l'idée même d'un effort national semble
souvent s'être effacé on comprend
Mathieu le résultat de ce sondage au
doxa
selon vous il y a aussi les politiques
mais aussi les médias et oui alors je
vous conseille
un rapport
de Jean Jaurès rapport qui est vraiment
intéressant à tout point de vue il parle
de cette fatigue informationnelle alors
on est bombardé d'informations alors
déjà on est perdu parce que bombardé et
dans ce bombardement d'informations
elles sont quasiment toutes négatives
pas un jour ne passe sans qu'on ait une
alerte sur notre smartphone sur la
guerre en Ukraine sans qu'un journal
télé nous dise que il va falloir se
chauffer à 19 degrés peut-être même un
peu moins qui a pu te céréales que les
prix explosent que la planète brûle et
que Vladimir Poutine va peut-être
balancer une bombe nucléaire très
honnêtement le rôle des politiques et
des médias c'est mais vraiment urgemment
de remonter le moral des Français
j'espère qu'on ne va pas participer à
cette fatigue informationnelle avec avec
ce débat on en parlait tout à l'heure de
du niveau des aides est-ce que le risque
ce n'est pas déconnecter les Français de
la réalité économique notamment sur le
plan énergétique et quelles conséquence
un moment où on doit changer nos
comportements si c'est un risque
important il y a il y a un risque aussi
enfin clairement
les villes actuellement pour soutenir le
pouvoir d'achat des Français sont des
dépenses excessives c'est de l'argent
c'est il y a certains ménages qui les
touchent bien sûr que non pas pour
certains mais il est excessif dans
verser à tous il est excessif que le
bouclier est tarifaire s'adresse à
absolument tous les consommateurs de la
même façon et donc c'est quelque chose
qui va dans le mauvais sens quand je
vois toutes les alertes qui sont tout
d'un coup donné et qu'on explique tout
d'un coup maintenant au niveau
gouvernemental qu'il va falloir baisser
la température dans les appartements à
19 degrés mais depuis des années ça
devrait être fait en fait depuis des
années parce que c'est du gaspillage
d'énergie et la rénovation des logements
aurait dû être engagée et
la température de chauffage aurait dû
être abaissé régulièrement rien
n'empêche il était énergétique dans les
entreprises aussi ah mais la sobriété
vous savez que c'était un gros mot
jusqu'à il y a 6 mois c'était un gros
mot il pour pour le
le gouvernement enfin quel qu'il soit
d'ailleurs jusqu'à lors évoquer la
sobriété c'était d'une certaine façon
faire allusion à la décroissance à
quelque chose qui était vu comme comme
absolument tabou et mal expliqué donc ça
c'est un véritable problème justement la
récession c'est pas la première marche
sur la décroissance non je ne crois pas
sincèrement je ne crois pas je dirais
que la récession c'est une pause dans la
croissance qui va avoir des effets par
exemple sur la sur les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre et dépression sur les
ressources naturelles mais ce sont des
effets transitoires aucun comportement
n'est changé au fond lors d'une lors
d'une lors d'une récession on a pu le
constater au moment de la récession du
au covid les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre on diminué à peu près autant que
la croissance au niveau mondial un peu
plus au niveau français c'est à peu près
autant que la croissance et c'est
reparti comme comme avant l'année
d'après on va sans doute battre des
records de nouveau des missions
mondiales de CO2 la décroissance c'est
autre chose la décroissance c'est un
ensemble de modifications structurelles
des modes de consommation et des modes
de production et qui aboutissent à une
sobriété pérenne là c'est uniquement
d'une certaine façon un épisode de
privation un épisode de jeûne
qui disparaîtra Raphaël est-ce que le la
flambée des prix de l'énergie ça peut
continuer continuer continuer François
Villeroy de galau qui est le patron de
la Banque de France reprenait cette
vieille métaphore économique disant les
arbres ne montent pas jusqu'au ciel
absolument non et puis on va faire un
peu d'optimiste les médias moi je suis
journaliste on va nourrir un tout petit
peu d'optimiste d'abord un mot sur la
décroissance la décroissance c'est
l'appauvrissement généralisée des
populations je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit la voie d'autant plus quand une
démocratie ça sera l'objet d'un autre
débat et je vous promets quand vous
réalisez
sur les prix de l'énergie l'Europe est à
la tâche
le gouvernement sont en train d'essayer
de réguler un marché devenu fou
ultra spéculatif la production le coût
de production de l'électricité nucléaire
en France c'est 40 euros le
mégawattheure c'est pas 550 donc il va
falloir refroidir la machine et on va
trouver des moyens de refroidir cette
machine on parlait de récession on a
vécu une récession séculaire pendant la
crise de la covid de quasiment 10% le
pouvoir d'achat des Français a augmenté
avec une récession de 8 ou 9%. a
augmenté parce que l'État est là pour
protéger ce que le consommateur ne paye
pas aujourd'hui sur la facture il faut
se rendre compte quand même on parlait
la question du ciblage des aides tout à
l'heure c'est vrai que ce bouclier
tarifaire coûte extrêmement cher et
certains politiques s'interrogent sur le
timing peut-être la tour mis en place
trop tôt en France on est le premier
pays à avoir dès le mois d'octobre 2021
mis à une protection sur le gaz et du
coup on a été parmi les plus protégés
d'Europe exactement mais du coup les
Français ne se sont peut-être pas rendu
compte de l'envoler des prix de
l'énergie certains députés le rapport du
budget par exemple à l'Assemblée
nationale pardon c'est dur de débrancher
la perfusion peut-être qu'on aurait dû
augmenter et pour expliquer après qu'on
protéger parce qu'il y a tout ce débat
sur le ciblage des aides qui
politiquement est très compliqué c'est
un vrai sujet au sein de l'exécutif en
ce moment parce que ce que les députés
entendent dans leur circonscription
c'est que les ministres entendent quand
ils se déplacent c'est une classe
moyenne les gilets jaunes aussi qui
explique que et ben nous les aides on ne
veut pas qu'ils soient ciblés sur les
plus modestes nous sommes les
travailleurs nous sommes ceux qui payons
des taxes et nous on n'a jamais droit à
rien c'est un discours qui monte qui est
assez dangereux qui est faux qui est
faux parce que les 50 milliards de
pouvoir d'achat et de boucliers c'était
pour l'ensemble des Français les 46
milliards de boucliers 2023 c'est pour
l'ensemble des Français mais donc il y a
un véritable sujet politique et
sociologique là-dedans j'en termine pour
dire que reste-toi optimiste on est
quand même extrêmement protégé la
facture des ménages qui se chauffe au
gaz ou à l'électricité aurait dû
augmenter de 150 à 200 euros par mois
l'année prochaine l'augmentation ne sera
que de 20 à 25 euros une minute pour
conclure est-ce que c'est juste une sale
année à passer comme disait le même
François Villeroy de Gallo patron de la
Banque de France 2023 pour vous c'est
probablement une salade à passer mais il
faut faire en sorte que les conséquences
de cette salade soient pas durable et
c'est ça un peu le les l'enjeu pour le
gouvernement de nouveau que
maintenir le pouvoir d'achat parce que
il y a des risques politiques on a parlé
des gilets jaunes mais c'est vrai que la
tension politique peut être très forte
on va voir ce qui va se passer avec la
réforme des retraites tensions aussi sur
les entreprises de nouveaux sont à
parler une gros risque de nouvelles
phase de désindustrialisation donc il
faudrait pas que ce qui se passe de
façon cette année et des conséquences
durables sur sur notre tissu productif
bien c'est la fin de ce débat et donc la
fin de cette émission merci d'y avoir
participé on a essayé de parler
d'économie de façon un peu claire et pas
forcément trop trop négative merci à
vous de l'avoir regardé je vous retrouve
lundi avec Thomas Hugues pour un nouveau
numéro de sens public et c'est le
général des portes qui sera demain
l'invité de la matinale de Public Sénat
à 8h bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]